[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
safe hold by David Weber is a series of
science fiction books dealing with
themes such as the use of religion to
manipulate the masses the inherent
conflict between dogma and Innovation
and progress and the corrupting effect
that power has on those who possess it
this series is set in the 24th century
at a time where humankind has colonized
multiple star systems in this era
humanity is very technologically
advanced and it seems that the universe
is Theirs to uncover
that is until they discover that a
nearby civilization has been devastated
by some other alien race
Humanity understood that this was a
hostile race of beings they knew that
this conflict would come for them
eventually so they prepared well for it
Ten Years Later the attack comes
Humanity assumed that their technology
and fighting force could fend off the
invading aliens but they were wrong
the severity of the opening a baba
attack even if it had been thrown back
had been a brutal wake-up call every
Federation world had begun arming and
fortifying when the first evidence of
the kababa's existence had appeared ten
years before Creswell after Cresswell
those preparations have been pressed at
a frenetic pace and a star system made
an awesome Fortress the surviving Fleet
elements had fallen back on the fixed
defenses standing and fighting to the
death in defense of Humanity's worlds
and they made the kababa pay a hideous
price in dead and broken Starships
had chosen to pay it
though Humanity fights bravely they
cannot stand against the unrelenting
might of the kababa diplomacy is
attempted several times but the aliens
do not respond to any human attempts at
communication all attempts are met with
cold silence the deafening Silence of
the kababa as they annihilate humanity
is chilling to contemplate a species
being destroyed without even the
slightest acknowledgment that they were
any more than pests being dealt with
with the callous Precision of a
persistent exterminator not even the
xenologist had been able to come up with
a satisfactory explanation for why the
kababa flatly refused to even consider
negotiations
they or they're translating computers at
any rate obviously comprehended Standard
English since they'd clearly used
captured data and documents and the
handful of broken scarred human
prisoners who had been recovered from
them had been interrogated with a casual
dispassionate brutality that was
horrifying so Humanity had known
communication with them was at least
possible yet they'd never responded to a
single official communication attempt
except to press their attacks harder
similar to some Concepts and other books
I've covered like blindsight by Peter
Watts these life forms are suggested not
to be conscious at all human beings are
conscious there is something that exists
within us that has become more than mere
intelligence we think and yet something
else perceives those thoughts something
else recognizes the fact that we are
thinking
books like this one and blindsight
suggest that to assume that other
intelligent beings would be the same is
a flawed line of thinking personally pay
wondered if they were actually still
capable of a reasoned response at all
some of the ships the Federation had
captured or knocked out and been able to
examine had been ancient almost beyond
belief at least one according to the
scientists who'd analyzed it had been
built at least two Millennia before its
capture yet there was no indication of
any significant technological Advance
between the time of its construction and
its final battle ships which has all
been had suggested were brand new
construction had mounted identical
weapons computers hyperdrives and sensor
suits that suggested a degree of
cultural stagnation which even pays
ancestral China at its most conservative
rejection of the outside world had never
approached
one which made even ancient Egypt seem
like a hotbed of innovation it was
impossible for pay to conceive of any
sentient beings who could go that long
without any major advances so perhaps
the gababa no longer were sentient in
the human sense of the term perhaps
everything all this was simply the
result of a set of cultural imperatives
so deeply ingrained they'd become
literally instinctual
the kababa appeared to have at one point
been sentient but over the course of
their evolution Consciousness became
unnecessary the idea that a species
could evolve to be sentient only to lose
the trait entirely is very interesting
to me it implies that Consciousness was
somehow evolutionarily useful at one
point in the species history but once
they reached a certain point in their
development it became no longer
beneficial
Humanity does eventually evade the
kababa but not before the vast majority
of humans are killed eight million
humans are sent to colonize a new world
which they called safe hold where they
would live without technology
the aliens could detect them if their
technology became too advanced the 8
million are referred to as the atoms and
Eaves the planet's safe hold was
slightly smaller than Earth and its
Planetary Cycles were somewhat different
but perfectly acceptable the safe
holding day was 26 hours and 31 minutes
long the years were approximately 301
days in length approximately 91 percent
the length of an earth year safehold had
one major Moon which rotated in a 28-day
cycle there were 10 months in each year
divided into 10 5-day weeks
the original plan had been to heavily
restrict industrialization the problem
is the administrator Langhorne has a bit
of a God complex he makes it so the
colonist's memories are altered so that
they no longer remember the past they
believe they are the first humans
Langhorne sets himself up as the prophet
of a cult known as the Church of God
awaiting
through his religion he hoped to prevent
the kababa from locating them by
reinforcing technological prohibition
with an iron fist the character Pei Shan
way understands that this will
eventually go horribly wrong on safehold
she creates Alexandria the last Refuge
of human knowledge an obvious reference
to the real world Library of Alexandria
and like the library of Alexandra it is
destroyed in the struggle between pay's
followers and langhorns eventually both
Langhorne and Pei Shan Wei are killed
this Sparks the war of the Fallen
between those who would see Humanity's
future illuminated in knowledge and
those who would shroud the future and
the past in darkness eventually the
latter wins out Langhorne becomes
deified with even the moon and special
days and times of day being named after
him while peishan way is demonized and
the ruins of Alexandra become known as
the accursed place Armageddon Reef 800
years later however
backup plan begins patronway had created
a cybernetic version of one of her best
tactical officers nimu Alban she had all
of the original humans memories and
skills at the time of nimu's Awakening
there are about 1 billion humans on
safehold
throughout the 10 books of the series
nimu Alban Works to undermine the Church
of God awaiting and promote science and
Innovation on stronghold which has by
this time formed into a Theocratic
feudal society nimu knows they must
bring down the church in order to
restore Humanity's real history and
technology so that they can prepare for
the inevitable re-encounter with the
kebaba eventually in the series we also
learn about the monks of saint zerno
who secretly protected the written
memory of the long forgotten human
Federation which at once fled the kababa
though this Series has many elements of
Science Fiction the pre-industrial
environment on safe hold is definitely
reminiscent of some fantasy series that
I've read There are Kings Emperors sword
fighting battles by ship huge Wars the
main recurring character of the series
nymu even takes the form of a man named
Merlin and acts as an advisor to King
Harold the name Merlin is an obvious
reference to the wizard advisor to King
Arthur in Arthurian Tales
the Sci-Fi elements exist mainly as a
backdrop and backstory to the main
aspect of the story which revolves
around the conflict of who chooses the
future for mankind don't go into this
series expecting everything to be
resolved quickly this is an ongoing
series with the most recent book being
published in 2019 these books are an
investment with a huge amount of
characters locations and plots so if you
like that kind of World building this
might be the series for you though I do
acknowledge that it might be a bit
overwhelming for some people
have you read the safe hold books if so
what do you think also let me know what
other science fiction books you'd like
to see me cover on this channel thanks
guys
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]